思えらセンター試験というかバルカは今こう増税の人はちょっとこの先受けなきゃいけ
ないんですけどこの先センター試験なくなるって言われてる数なんともいるんですけど
センター試験っていうのはもし君たちが大学に行きたい時に
まぁ今のところはセンター試験を受けるのがうま
普通っちゃ普通な事なんですよセンター試験っていうのがね
基本的に丸くシートなんですよね僕を持ったなぁ
サイコロ振ってもにー点数取れるんじゃねって思うんです
まあ僕みたいな強運の持ち主はねきっともうサイコロ振るだけでももう何点使い点数が
取れるだろうということで今回実際に最後の振って試そうと思います今回やるのは英語
で英語の問題消えることしたら基本的に4タテ問題か6卓文
確かでないんでドキュメントサイコロと4面のサイコロを準備しました
今年のあの2月とかにあったりばませんだ試験の問題よ下に不用意したんで一部は
とりあえず分の作るだけでやってみようと思いますでもう一つは完全にもサイコロだけ
の力を使った
成績を出してじゃあまず自力でやります
じゃあ今本当に回答とか何も知らないから
ちょっとん
ガチでやらせていただきますこっちはは
だろう得たり辺の点数取ったらたたかれるようなあー
じゃあ行きます
4を
4日ん
マッハ
いい
順調だろ曇りよはい終わりました喜屋武的にもこんなもんだと思います
あっっドンライブわかんないけど多分ちょうどいい時間ぐらいだと思います
ん
震度やをちょっと話ね本当の俺の今の a子のセンター試験の実力を解凍すると思い
ますネットに回答があるんで
立止まっててくださいな達ありますから
留学したからってこういう試験の点数が上がるわけじゃないんですよ
映画化はこう基礎的なへ地上の会はなんでなんかそういうこういうさんっていうか
ちょっと難しい方は僕できないんだもの山本当に甘えきっずしてきた
5-4おっしゃかムーン集いよよしきた
予約やべーぞおいこれあ間違えた
ねえねえ間違ってるよねえ
佐藤これ発音だめだがやっぱり
兄ちゃん31
芳佳日か要因4234
ちょっと待ってやばいやばいやばいだろ間違ってる
ちょっとやばいよん
止めセンターおりだ俺台のバカになっちゃってる
して飲んでたふざけ
ん
きゃっての49は市など4市
50七夕の笹中
やバーをレコちょっとやっぱり英語って前に進んだけ下がりますよ
これはやべぇば
結果168年でした
200点中
ちょっとショックを受けていますの
ええええええ
ちょっと勉強しようまずで今回のメインは僕の天井ずありませんこのサイコロを使って
ボブしたグログジャージ店壊れるかどうかっていう問題です
その回答を見ながらもうやりますねじゃあ行きます
ちょっと止めうあざった
やばいな最初かなでもにで撮ったぞに2点3
スピードは全然早いですね
いやもう全然多分普通にやるより全然速いと思うんだよ
ならね買えば無理ですよ
や5361労をとっりこってと
並べ替え問題一個ってだ
4保育
ん
=4
はい結果が出ましたサイコロでセンター試験英語した結果
200点中
すー
64点ですみんな勉強しようねっ
ban
dea